he showing up
right now
welcome everybody to another episode of
the into the impossible podcast this one
is kind of like an office hours uh
episode with your chance to talk to one
of the renowned astronomers of our time
someone who works on
observation and works uh on the
interface with new uh theories
and on instrumentation and that's uh my
colleague in the university of
california the world's best university
dr jessica liu joining us from uc
berkeley's astro department how are you
jessica
i'm doing great thanks for having me
brian yeah it's such a great pleasure
yeah as soon as i heard these results
i was immediately hoping that you would
uh honor me by coming on the podcast and
uh and you did so i'm super grateful for
that
and um i'm hoping that we will get a
chance to take questions from the
audience as we like to do so we had um
we had recently adam reese who's another
observational astronomer of some note um
and he uh he was on live we take
questions from the audience some of them
are pre-asked some of them will be asked
as we go along
on this conversation and you have some
materials to show but i think maybe
first um
kind of set the scene you've um i always
knew you as i said as a renowned
astronomer observational astronomer with
an interest in galaxies um if i remember
correctly and kind of traditional
observational and instrumental methods
uh this
may not be a departure for you but in my
recollections it is so i could be the
absentminded professor effect can you um
can you tell me where does this fort fit
in in the jessica liu brand portfolio um
where are black holes in that is this a
new research endeavor is this something
you've long been interested in
yeah ever since i was an undergraduate
at mit i've always been fascinated by
this interface between astronomy and
physics uh particularly sort of exotic
forms of matter or black holes that's
that's always been my interest where can
we really push the boundaries of our
physics knowledge by looking out into
the universe so when i was an undergrad
i actually studied neutron stars with
vicky caspy
and then i took a break and worked as a
software engineer in industry in silicon
valley for a little while but as soon as
i got back to grad school my first
interests at ucla was working on the
supermassive black hole at the center of
our galaxy so that was a lot of my early
work is working on the galactic center
trying to understand how stars evolve
and are form and born and die all around
a whopping big black hole at the center
of our galaxy
yeah
yeah so the yeah the stellar mass black
holes work that we're talking about
today and that you've seen in the press
that's all
using the same techniques which called
astrometry it's the ability to measure
the positions of stars on the sky so
that's really where it was born it was
born because we were doing all this hard
work on the center of our galaxy to
watch store stars orbit the black hole
and we can use the same exact techniques
to look for these small baby black holes
the stellar mass black holes oh
and this particular black hole isn't
necessarily at the very center of the
milky way galaxy is it
no not at all so turns out our big
galaxy is swarming with black holes at
least we think
it should be swarming with stellar mass
black holes so we can look a lot closer
to home
but the technique that we're using
called gravitational lensing which we'll
talk about in a little while
really is done best towards where the
galaxy's really crowded so we like to
look towards the center roughly not
right at the center but a little bit off
and we're using the background
field of really crowded stars as a
screen to hunt for uh stellar mass black
holes that are in the foreground
and how does this work fit in with the
recent guest we had on shep dolmen in
the event horizon telescope is is there
any hope for black holes like the one
you're going to describe today
that event horizon could verify this
this you know amazing startling
discovery that you and your team have
made or is it hopeless because the mass
levels are so small compared to the
monster black hole that we always talk
about
right i really wish we could but there's
two ingredients that are missing uh one
is on the universe side in order to see
black holes in the way that the event
horizon telescope looks for them you
have to have gas accreting onto the
black hole you still need
electromagnetic radiation coming from
right around the event horizon to see it
so that's one ingredient that's missing
the second one is that the event horizon
telescope as large as it is as big as
it's spread out over the whole earth
it's nowhere near big enough to resolve
these tiny little stellar mass black
hole event horizons i always like to
remind everyone the stellar mass black
hole event horizon is only about 30
kilometers in size it's like the size of
a city these things are so so tiny so
yeah we would need you know solar system
sized event horizon telescope
right well we can put in a request for
uh nsf funding for that as we go on uh
so reminder we're talking with jessica
lew colleague in the university of
california system uh a really incredibly
productive you know i've always followed
your career
had aspirations that you might be a
colleague in san diego but uh but that
uh that
you know we'll talk about that later i
have to talk to the dean uh but but at
any rate you're uh you're so creative
and what you do
is use tools of astronomy to understand
astrophysical processes and new objects
talk about um what this discovery meant
maybe we can go to the screen share
and then i want to talk about um how did
you realize that this discovery
you know had the significance that we're
just now realizing it it does so we can
go to a screen share if you press that
button and then we'll
remind folks that they can take we will
take questions in just a bit so let me
add that um i'm going to take myself
actually hold on i'm going to switch
screens here i've got this whole mobile
command center here jessica you'd be so
impressed
but uh but often it is
a little more trouble technologically
okay so now we are seeing your uh your
twitter feed which is how the world
discovered it uh first and uh and i
immediately recognized my opportunity to
finally get you on the show uh so walk
us through this first of all everyone
should follow jessica lou jaylou
j lu underscore astro
on twitter and her feed is uh phenomenal
not only for the astronomy that we get
into just but all the like lifestyles of
the rich maybe and famous professors
you share so much cool content on what
it's like to be a professor i want to
get into academia too with you if you'll
indulge me later but uh but anyway uh
everyone follow jessica please and don't
forget you can submit questions on
youtube or on twitter at either one of
our feeds so take it away with this
magnificent twitter storm
sure yeah so i set this up because you
know a lot of times you read a press
release and it's great you're really
intrigued do you hop in and you just
want to know a little more right what
does this discovery mean where did it
come from
if you recall way back if you ever took
an astronomy class in college maybe you
sort of remembered something but you
want a refresher that's kind of what i
put this together for so it's really to
set the stage what does it mean to be a
black hole to find a black hole why are
they interesting why are they important
so i think that maybe the first place to
start is
here so when stars die
if they're big stars really massive
stars say 10 times heavier than our sun
we think they will collapse and leave
behind either a black hole or a neutron
star
what's funny is we teach all of our
undergraduates if you're eight times as
massive as the sun you'll turn into a
neutron star and if you're 20 or 30
times as massive as the sun you'll turn
into a black hole the reality is we
don't actually know those numbers very
well uh that's a big puzzle for us and
what we used to tell everyone we think
now might be wrong so that's a lot of
what motivates our work is which stars
die and leave behind black hole ghosts
and which ones die and leave behind
neutron star ghosts
it's yeah
i'd say that's the first bit
so then uh we do know of black holes we
know they exist in the universe and a
lot of what we know comes from looking
in our own galaxy at black holes that
have companions so this is a little uh
swarm or family picture family photo of
all of the black holes with companions
that we know about in our own milky way
you can see it's pretty small there's
only about two dozen they all of these
have bright companions that are dumping
gas onto the black hole it's a falling
in accreting and then it glows in the
x-rays so this hot gas that varies with
time is how we recognize the these
systems these black hole systems exist
in the first place then we monitor the
star watch it wander around use that to
measure the mass and show whether it's a
black hole or a neutron star
so that's a we know a couple dozen but
you see they're all in these binary
systems all with companions
these days the black hole
family picture is growing even larger
these are all the black holes that have
been found now with gravitational waves
these are the ripples in space-time that
are
propagating through the universe from
many distant galaxies these are not in
our own milky way galaxy and so each one
of these combos of two blue points here
is a binary black hole that merged and
sent out its gravitational wave siren
that we're now able to detect you see
there's now almost 100 black holes and
even a few neutron stars where they've
measured their masses figured out where
they came from what they turned into
so this is a big family portrait the
only problem is everything's still in a
binary system so if we want to know
where black holes came from what kind of
stars they died
originally had and then died from
the binaries are not enough the binaries
are really messy they had only the close
companions or the binaries we can probe
today only these tight binary black
holes are the ones we can see what about
the things that are far apart what about
the things that aren't in binaries at
all that are all isolated and lonely
black holes
that's what we think most of them are we
think most of them are probably just
floating around isolated not doing
anything not creating any gas not
growing
something like 100 million in our own
milky way probably of these
free-floating ghost black holes
and so that's where this work comes in
is how do we go about sort of filling in
the gap between these binary black holes
and their progenitor stars and find the
free-floating isolated ones uh that are
that are out there and that we think are
so numerous
so that's where gravitational
microlensing comes in uh brian have you
ever used microlensing in galaxies or
cosmology
well we use it in
we use it quite frequently in the cmb
not to look at
necessarily innards of galaxies or stars
but we are looking for the imprint of
other massive objects including
neutrinos on the clustering properties
of galaxies which are in the foreground
for the cmb so we do use it but not not
quite in this way it's a ubiquitous tool
in astronomy though you're absolutely
right
yeah so gravitational lensing is pretty
fun because it's gravity is just a
property of matter everything is
providing gravity and lensing all of the
background objects behind it so we just
used that same as as brian said
ubiquitous technique but we're hunting
for these isolated stellar mass black
holes this is a fun little animation
that my postdoc matthew freeman put
together where he just took a picture of
the sun this is not real we can't
observe this unfortunately
he took the picture of the sun and sent
it behind a black hole and you see what
the gravity of the black hole does to
the light that's coming from that
background star it warps it so instead
of seeing one picture you actually see
two pictures of the same thing
and then it warps it and turns it into
these arcs very temporarily
what's really fun is you can do this
experiment at home if you go and take a
wine glass and you hold it up in front
of a light bulb or a candle you can see
the bottom of your wine glass produce
the exact same effect it's really fun
the multiple images the little arcs
makes the candle brighter the black hole
is doing exactly the same thing to the
background light is this comparable in
mass to what the black hole is
potentially that you've discovered or is
this just a more massive one
yeah this is not the right geometry the
star is really close to the black hole
just behind it in this case and we're
way zoomed in so unfortunately all of
our modern telescopes can't see these
two images we can't see the arcs
so instead yeah our picture's a lot
a lot lower resolution and of course
einstein didn't think that it would be
possible to
detect this uh gravitational lensing i
love the paper which is just like a
letter can you imagine jessica if we
could just write to nature just like on
a cocktail napkin and say i think he
said like a while ago my friend mr
mandel came by and asked me to do a
little calcul
he's basically derives uh gravitational
lensing in uh you know in a napkin that
he sends and immediately gets published
good for him i mean i'm looking for
forward to those days someday jessica
i don't know the observational paper
that confirmed the periaps procession of
mercury which was the the validation of
general relativity uh that paper was a
lot longer yeah that's true
[Laughter]
yeah so this is fun too uh so this is a
second view but looking top down again
to kind of give you a sense so if we're
here on earth
now let's see i could probably blow this
up here yeah there we go can you still
see it brian um it says click
is there um
can you just like zoom in on the actual
web page because now it's i i just see
it says click to exit full screen uh
yeah okay so it didn't here i'll just
leave it here then so let's say we're
here out on earth here's our milky way
galaxy we could never get this picture
because you have to fly out of our
galaxy to see it but we're looking
towards the center and we see some
random background star and we're waiting
for a black hole to just have a chance
coincident alignment and you can see
when that does happen the light rays
from that background star bend towards
us so that's kind of what we're looking
for that's exactly the signal that we're
looking for is that chance alignment of
the black hole and star temporarily and
as it moves in front it bends the light
rays and makes the background star look
brighter
and it also makes it take a little jaunt
on the sky it makes it wobble around a
little bit
yes
so that's kind of what we're doing is
we're i won't go through all of these
the twitter feeds up you can definitely
see it but here's kind of the actual
data so this is from a ground-based
telescope called ogle it's a survey
the telescope's located in chile and
it's staring towards this very crowded
star field all the time just waiting to
see a little popcorn like this as you
see in the middle it brightens and then
it goes away
and then here's the measurements of what
happens down on the bottom it brightens
with time for a very short period of
time and then falls away
so that's the signal we're looking for
that's the signal of gravitational
microlensing
but this alone doesn't tell you whether
it's a black hole or just a foreground
star or brown door for exoplanet that
might be doing the gravity right so my
my colleague kim grist
who coined the term macho i believe uh
he
uh you know he and his colleagues i
think some from berkeley search for this
effect in the halo of the milky way by
looking at i think the s small
magellanic cloud
and he used this to set limits on the
amount he and his team to set limits of
the amount of macho's massive compact
halo objects that there could be to
potentially solve the dark matter crisis
problem which is a topic for another day
but um how can you be sure these aren't
you know because they did found a lot of
um you know machos there are tons and
tons of these things there's just not
enough to make up enough
dark matter to account for the missing
gap between baryonic dark matter and
total dark matter how do you know that
these are black holes or not just
ordinary jupiters or
something less
less exotic
yeah so if i go back up to
this picture
so in let me see if it'll play there we
go so if you look on the lower left and
lower right here you see that it gets
brighter and fades away but there's also
a change a wobble on the sky
and that wobble on the sky if you can
measure that with astrometry as i
mentioned earlier you can measure the
lens mass
so you can tell is this thing a tiny
jupiter that's you know a 100 earth
masses or a small fraction of a stellar
mass is it a star that's one solar mass
or is it a black hole that's 10 solar
masses
so we use both the little wobble on the
sky which is the thing that's really
hard to measure and we're only just now
measuring the first astrometric
microlensing signals
so that's really the key difference
and you also get color information
as well like you can show that the
lensing event takes place for all
wavelengths or not yet
so you can do that uh we do in fact have
that because we observed with ogle and
two different filters and we observed
with hubble space telescope and two
different wavelength ranges so that's
all there too and that's an important
piece of the puzzle to make sure that
it's not um
this thing is let's say it's three solar
masses it could be a three solar mass
star
so we use the color information to tell
us hey no there's no starlight here
both the color of it is wrong and just
the overall brightness of the lens
itself is is wrong
so we can we can infer all of that so
it's the size of that astrometric wobble
that you'll see going there plus the the
color and brightness information those
two things tell us the mass of the lens
and whether it's bright or dark
and that's the fake data the real data
is down here
so you can see the signal we're trying
to measure is pretty tiny
right so we expect the star to move on
the gray line and instead it moves on
this red line right there
yeah so it's a pretty pretty tiny
measurement uh it's about one milliarc
second on the sky
and
that's kind of like measuring if you
could take a picture with your camera of
the surface of the moon somebody
standing up there it's like the
equivalently trying to watch their
eyelashes blink
the kind of scale of the measurement
we're trying to make how big is the ogle
telescope diameter
so the ogle telescope doesn't isn't able
to measure this this this is measured
with hubble the ogle yeah alcohol's
still a decently in fact it's bigger
than hubble it's you know a three meter
telescope but it's on the ground so the
earth's atmosphere blurs everything out
makes it makes your images very fuzzy
and so you can't measure positions very
well but hubble because it's in space
and doesn't have to contend with the
earth's atmosphere gives us much sharper
images and we can measure this
astrometric signal the position of the
star way better
were you able to get the hubble uh
telescope time ahead of time was it
based on the fact that you had done some
measurements with other instruments or
did you is it serendipitous you know and
that you found this by accident
tell walk us through the order of
operations did you kind of suspect you
could detect this guy but didn't know
exactly where to look or how did you
really zero in on this it's fascinating
yeah so it's kind of funny way back when
i was a post-doc at caltech so i just
graduated i'd been working on the
galactic center and i was looking for
new projects and new ideas and caltech's
a great place to be innovative right you
can go and have coffee with colleagues
and they'll ask hey you know i have this
idea and with this work and i'm like
yeah the technique works we can do this
astrometrically this would be really fun
and then we wrote a proposal and tried
to uh to do this at first with the keck
telescopes
so uh yeah so we we thought we could do
it we proved to ourselves we could do it
technologically and that we think that
there were enough signals out there
black holes swarming around to to find
them and we put in our first proposals
and started our first experiment and we
started with just three targets
and
uh two of them were really crappy
weather you know just cloudy during the
event so it didn't work out so well and
then the other one we didn't see a
signal it just kept following you know
the expected line the gray line so to
speak but we proved to ourselves we
could do it that you know the signal was
our ability to measure was good enough
that we could have seen a black hole if
it was there so that's how we got
started it wasn't very exciting work and
the result you know
i i wasn't on your show actually the
show didn't exist but uh you know for a
non-detection you don't get much
right much impressed
oops sorry about that the lights going
off but you know that's how we started
and that's what we had to do that hard
work to show it was possible technology
uh technologically wise
yeah and then uh to connect hubble in um
so after uh we we did that project we
started proposing to work with keck
again and then our uh colleagues at
space telescope a team led by kailash
sahu who's on the competitor paper
they started using hubble data so we
kind of went in parallel we were working
with keck and they were working with
hubble
to try and find these black holes i see
hold on give me just a minute there we
go trying to trigger the trick the
lights to coming back on all about
saving energy in
california so if you don't move
a muscle in your body that we the
governor shuts off our light so
it's rough
all
right yeah so i think then um the
hubble data for this target the way we
we sort of we use two telescopes so we
use one telescope which is a
ground-based telescope to just
constantly be looking for possible
microlensing events that's what ogle and
the ogle survey and the moa survey do
these are on ground-based telescopes
constantly staring and making images and
movies like this
and then we have to pick out there's
maybe
a thousand two thousand microlensing
events every year
and of those
maybe a handful five might be black
holes wow
right so how do you pick out the needle
in the haystack
so i think that's the the fun part of
the job is picking which targets you're
going to look at
um and uh we have to be really careful
we we start observing them we decide
right about here
this one's going to be a good black hole
candidate we don't know but we're going
to try
and then we point keck or hubble at the
peak when the right at the peak of the
event and then we have to follow it all
the way down for several years
and right so you're using the ground
base to select it on the left side of
the curve and then
hubble and then ogle again or i mean you
can't get
five years of hubble time dedicated i'm
sure right
not dedic not the whole time no so we're
constantly continuing to watch with ogle
or moa and then the hubble data we take
you know one or two or three
measurements uh in the first year and
then one measurement year two another
one and three four but we're just taking
one measurement right so that's why this
astrometric curve is so sparse right
there's no it's not all filled in
there's just a point there a point there
a year later a year later a year later
so it's a long term program for sure a
very patient one
yeah my grad students already aren't
always happy about that right it's a
project that takes longer than a grad
career
i know well i say it depends on how long
the grad career
half-life is in your group
i say start complaining around the
eighth year and then i start listening
to when we can make red no i'm just
kidding i've never had someone take
eight years
uh seven but not eight no um so great
okay cool so we've gotten over the
right so we're extra playing down and
then what if you saw something strange
you know at what point
i mean do you want to really catch how
important is it to catch that very most
peak point you know because that
seems like that could be pretty
crucially relevant are you less sparsely
sampling at that point and really
densely trying to cover it
yeah so the uh that's absolutely the
case so in the first year um you'd like
to have more measurements but actually
the peak of when the when the astrometry
peak happens is not at the same time
that the brightening peak happens
let's see i think i have in this paper
we have a fun figure here yeah so this
is the same event that same black hole
neutron star candidate that we're
talking about and you can see uh that
this is in time scales of days so this
is 2 000 days for each tick mark so the
peak of the astrometry doesn't actually
happen at time
0 which is close to this 56 000 there it
actually happens a little bit later a
lot later in fact like a year later
depending on the event so that's kind of
cool because we can
catch it at when it basically has almost
no
wobble and then catch the wobble and
then watch it fade away
that's kind of what we're doing and we
have the luxury of time with these black
hole candidates oh wow
very cool
yeah so then after that once we've got
both our brightness photometry
measurements and the position astrometry
measurements
we put it all into a really complex
modeling process to get out that lens
mass
and a bunch of other parameters too and
this is we did this for five targets
observed with hubble and this one which
is called ob110462
is the last one that has the biggest
masses
but the the hard work is that you can
see there's two possible masses two sort
of solutions that might be allowed at
least that's what we find in our data
the competing team finds a one solution
with a little bit higher mass but no
matter what these are in the mass regime
where they're more massive than stars
typically
in the neutron star black hole mass
range
and that's the real that's the
photometry data that i was talking about
there
so i unless you have other questions i
can show keep going down this where i
can stop sharing no no keep going
okay people are loving it yeah
yeah so the the black holes uh you know
the mass is one thing if it's bigger
than a sun-like star we know it could be
a black hole and then we have to show
it's dark and there's other figures in
the paper that go into why we think it's
dark but we're pretty both teams are
very confident about that
and so it's just really the masses that
we're debating
whether it's definitely a black hole
mass object or it's at the boundary
between a black hole and a neutron star
um so that's fun and then we can tell
all kinds of cool things we can tell how
fast the black hole might be moving
through the galaxy
uh you can see where like which
direction it's moving uh for the black
hole in black and which direction the
background star is moving and red so
there's all kinds of fun things and then
my very favorite part is
we can put together you know it's super
exciting you find a black hole that's
great but then what what do you do who
cares why is it a big deal
we put it all together so with a big old
computer model a mock milky way in our
computer we say
if we know
the milky way how many did we expect to
detect versus how many did we actually
detect
and so then we do this big old
population
synthesis where we say in some
microlensing parameter spaces don't
worry about the axes here where do we
expect things to fall that's all the
tiny little points those are all mock
simulations not real and we expect the
black holes to fall down here or down
here
and what did we actually find well we
found a bunch of stuff ended up up here
but this one event which is the black
and purple contours fell in this kind of
in-between
space
so then what's neat is we can use all of
them the detections the non-detections
to say is our picture of the milky way
right is the number of black holes what
we expected it to be is it too low is it
too high
are they moving as fast as we thought
they should what are their mass
distributions those are sort of the real
astrophysics questions that we're trying
to get at
so this is the first in the step where
you know we have a sample of five or six
targets we need to build up the sample
to really answer these population
questions
yeah so i think that's all i got
everything else is in the papers there's
a more fun animations if you'd like to
take a look
i'm happy to answer questions
yeah that's really great so we have uh
we have a couple of questions so far um
and then i'm reminding folks that we're
talking with professor jessica liu is a
astronomy professor at uc berkeley and
has been there for some time working
with her team
um also you mentioned quite a lot the
companion or competitor paper i guess um
people don't usually think of astronomy
as really competitive and and so forth
but uh can you talk about it what uh
what was the sensation of you know kind
of
not wanting to get scooped or something
like that how how did that figure into
it or you know how competitive really is
is the search
space
yeah so i think in science it's always
important to have someone checking
independently right doing independent
work especially for big results to make
sure that everything's right and so i'm
very used to working in situations where
are on science projects where there's
another team also working on the same
science project that's pretty typical
for a scientist
so when i worked on the galactic center
i worked at ucla with andrea guezz
and her group there and of course there
was a competitive team in germany led by
reinhart genzel and so we were always
both colleagues but always competing and
it's the same thing here
so
my group and my graduate student casey
lamb who led this work and just did a
phenomenal job
were always in competition and yet
friendly you know
collegial
interactions with the competing team
who's led by kailash sahu at space
telescope science institute so yeah it
was really fun to see both papers coming
out sort of at the same time together
and really
having that independent verification
that yeah indeed this is a free-floating
ghost star
either a black hole or neutron star
while we don't perfectly agree on every
single thing i think the main messages
we we mainly agree on and it just means
we have lots more fun work to do going
forward to figure out why there's
differences
right so you mentioned you know one of
the key enabling you know tools was the
hubble space telescope can you talk a
little bit about
upcoming measurements either with hubble
or could even the james webb spice
telescope give us
even more clues more data better data
how will that play in
so for this particular event we have one
more measurement coming with hubble this
fall in october so we're really hoping
to fold that last measurement in and
really you know see if we can uh
definitely pin down the mass is it a
black hole or is it a neutron star so
that's for this particular target uh
what i'm really excited about is we've
launched a second campaign
now that we've gone through this this
batch we've launched another campaign we
hope to start um this fall where we'll
do start five more now it'll take a
while these each take you know four
years uh to complete but we'll be able
to pick out four or five brand new
targets and and uh work on those and
we've got targets we haven't published
yet too another five from the keck
observatory so that population that i
was talking about is going to just grow
and grow and grow so that's really
exciting and that's both hubble and keck
are capable of making these measurements
along with the vlt in europe those are
the only three telescopes in the world
that can really do this
jwst will it help or or not
maybe
so
i'm really excited about jwst but we
have no idea how it will do with
astrometry the ability to measure
positions of stars because it's a floppy
telescope
right the the primary mirror is
segmented the segments warp they try to
keep them aligned but that might affect
the astrometry so we have a lot of
groundwork to do to see how good jw is
going to do at astrometry
both for this project and for the
galactic center projects i also work on
in fact i'm leading a jwst galactic
center proposal we're super excited to
get pictures of the galactic center from
jw this fall in august or so
will that
be dedicated towards black hole physics
or other astrophysics phenomena
so the jwst galactic center program is
is aimed at both so you can get black
hole science watch the accretion onto
the supermassive black hole you can get
stars science watching all the stars zip
around which ones are binaries which
ones look typical or unusual
and even what i'm super excited about
stellar mass black hole science so we
have some hints that we might be
watching stars wobble around stellar
mass black hole companions they're not
accreting they're still in binaries but
they're separated binaries compared to
like those ligo ones that i was showing
earlier
so we're hoping to use jwst to confirm
whether those are real or not
oh wow
and then we have a question from
ernesto's a friend of the show i'll put
it up there on my screen
would we be able to detect the presence
of black holes from similar types of
effects but on incoming neutrinos
do black holes affect neutrino
gravitational lensing in the same way
they do for light
in
yeah that's definitely tricky uh i think
there aren't so this signal requires a
lot of light to measure it and so i
would guess the neutrino streams are all
too
thin there's not enough neutrinos coming
in uh that we can detect or our ability
to detect them is not very very good
so in principle
maybe but you'd have to have a neutrino
source lined up with the black hole and
then you'd have to get enough neutrinos
and we'd have to have better detectors
so
that's my that's my
take on it but i am definitely no expert
in neutrinos probably neutrinos are
still in the regime where they name the
events after you know cartoon characters
and when they detect a neutrino at at
icecube they give it names like you know
ernie and burt and uh so if we did that
with photons uh we wouldn't have time
for anything else uh that's a good
question though thank you
um next question comes from uh
a person who actually stole the name
that i was going to name for my second
child his name is prometheus
prometheus unchained who asks both of us
what happens
to the space-time
in the electromagnetic radiation around
a black hole ring
rotating near the speed of light i i
guess this question maybe if i could
reimagine it reinterpret it prometheus
um you know what what is the nature of
uh space and time near these
free-floating black holes versus the
ones you see in interstellar or even the
ones the super super duper massive ones
at the center of m87 or even the milky
way how do they differ
yeah so the fun thing is that that
gravitational warping of space-time is
in a sense scale-free it can be a big
black hole or a small black hole but the
space response the space time around it
responds in the same way
it's just how the how much curvature
there is and that's all related to the
lens mass the mass of the black hole
so you scale up you get to a big
supermassive black hole that's more
massive you get more warping
at a fixed distance you scale down you
get less warping at a fixed distance but
if you convert into event horizon steps
not meters or you know kilometers or
miles if you just convert into units of
event horizons everything behaves the
same around a big black hole in a small
buckle so that's kind of neat and then
for us the stellar mass black holes that
we're seeing in gravitational lensing
the light rays that are coming in from
the background star they're not actually
perfectly aligned they're offset just a
little bit
and so uh the light rays are not passing
necessarily super close to the event
horizon they're they're going
approaching the black hole from a little
bit further away uh 10 60 100 event
horizons away and then getting bent and
warped back down if they were going too
close they would actually do crazy
things like wrap around the black hole
and be sent far far away from our
telescopes
uh someone whose name i won't pronounce
uh let's say it ends in dreams is asking
how do we know it's a black hole and not
a black sphere i guess my question to
you to reimagine that question
would be you know you you do kind of
couch in appropriate terms it could be a
neutron star um i don't think it would
be any less exciting you know it's like
i called the show ghost black hole but
you know ghost neutron star is pretty
damn scary too but anyway how do you
know like why did you use that specific
languages and you know i think it's a
it's a teachable thing for the audience
many of whom are grad students etc how
do you write a paper title and and
balance that you know kind of you know
uh need to get the appropriate detention
but also to be cautious and couch things
in the right terms why didn't why did
you say could be a neutron star
yeah so the the data still allows for
neutron star we know this thing is dark
but not so dark that it has to be a
black hole neutron stars are extremely
dark too now we're used to thinking
about neutron stars as pulsars
these would be a subset a small set of
neutron stars that are very young they
may still have a lot of electromagnetic
radiation coming to us in the form of
these pulsars
most neutron stars are cold they're dead
they have surfaces
but they're so cold that the light that
they're emitting is really really really
little uh and so you know that's it
imagine a neutron star is smaller than
pluto
it's on at times sizes of asteroids and
think about how bright asteroids are
they're very very dark by themselves
unless they're reflecting sunlight so if
you put an asteroid out into space it's
not going to emit hardly anything same
thing with a neutron star
so neutron stars are very dark but
they're not zero
and black holes are very dark to the
point where there's zero light coming
out so it's a really small difference
between a black hole and neutron star in
terms of brightness
it's only the masses that we sort of
think tell us which one is which
exactly
um
now a question which isn't really fully
fleshed out but i'm gonna kind of riff
on it from t-car it might be related to
messy car i'm not sure but uh t-car is
asking or just mention spin charge and
mass which are the three properties you
know black holes are kind of like
commodities you know they're fungible
you've seen one you've seen them all but
i'm wondering yeah could you could you
perhaps
address the question of what other
properties of black holes besides the
mass
could this technique enable if any and
you know don't feel pressured
to you know overreach on my behalf but
could you get at the spin and charge of
a black hole from this type of new
technique
i don't think so so charge almost
certainly not because uh it doesn't well
we don't really know how it would affect
the light rays that are coming in we
don't know that the charge would affect
light at all right so i don't think we
could probe the charge at all if it even
existed for astrophysical black holes
spin is another another game so
in principle yes but i don't think we
have the ingredients
nor the facilities to observe it so the
spin if you had a perfectly lined up
black hole and star which is extremely
rare to the point where it almost never
happens almost there's always a little
bit of offset between the two
but if they were perfectly lined up
maybe there would be an impact where the
einstein ring those arcs that i was
showing it turns into a full ring if
they're perfectly lined up that should
shrink in or out depending on the spin
of the black hole but the effect is
super small and we can't today resolve
the ring so i think we're a long long
way from being able to do that for
stellar mass black holes but of course
they're really excited to try this for
the event horizon telescope for
supermassive black holes where the event
horizon is big enough we can actually
see the ring right and maybe riffing on
that
will pivot to
the buzzword of the last decade a little
survey which was multi-messenger
astronomy george anderson is asking what
exactly is the mass of the ghost black
hole you're observing so i'm going to
just cut and paste
or read off the astromech has an
inferred lens mass of between 1.6
to 4.4 solar masses is that right
jessica
yeah that's our result and then kailash
sahoo's result paper has it around seven
solar masses so you know there's still a
decently uncertain mass but as we find
more of these and our measurements get
better we're hoping to find a bunch of
black holes and know their masses really
well
um
let's see ernesto again is asking a
question could there be a unique
topology for each black hole considering
that if all matters compress the order
fell in plus hawking radiation in other
words i guess does the topology of
space-time or geometry moreover
it really is only dependent on those
three properties right mass spin and
charge so no ernesto i think jessica if
you agree
there wouldn't be anything specifically
unique to topologically speaking
um different we have to dis entangle
topology from uh geometry so no i don't
i don't think so jessica am i wrong
right
as far as i know i no but you know there
are a whole suite down the hall of sort
of
quantum mechanical gravitational you
know people at that interface who are
trying to prove whether that's the case
or not so
someone i'm sure is working on it but
not that i know of
so in terms of multi-messenger astronomy
you mentioned multiple different
instruments that you're working on
um where do you see you know the future
the next 10 years of black halls is more
event horizon
data combined with stuff like this and
on kind of outskirts of black holes
in the in the galaxy not at the galactic
center how do you see the portfolio of
black hole astronomy
improving with new gaia data perhaps and
other things what does it landscape look
like
yeah i think it's a real revolution that
starts with the advent of ligo and
gravitational wave detections i mean we
went from
20 years of knowing a handful 10 20
black holes
all accreting from a companion to
overnight in the space of three or four
years uh you know multiplying that times
a factor of five and these are now dark
black holes with just another black hole
companion so it really is a game changer
the detection of gravitational waves so
there's a hundred black holes today five
years from now there are probably going
to be a thousand black holes known from
ligo gravitational wave and virgo
gravitational wave measurements the
black holes the isolated ones that we're
looking at we have one maybe now but
we're looking at after the roman space
telescope launches we predict there
could be hundreds from that survey so
again just
rapid rapid expansion of the black hole
landscape
gaia will find black holes in binaries
that are with distant companions not
accreting gas so we hope that number
will be in the hundreds if not thousands
yeah i think it's like the early days of
exoplanets where you were going from one
or a few every few years to suddenly
just an explosion of lots and lots and
lots of exoplanets and what's fun about
black holes is then you get to do all
kinds of cool astrophysics with it where
did they come from connect them back to
their stars how do they influence their
environments that's really what we're
looking forward to yeah awesome
channel warhorse
listener viewer is pointing out that
we've only known black holes exist or
predicted to exist since the 1930s so
they're not even 100 years old and and
yet they've revolutionized not only
our view of of you know the galaxy the
universe but also quantum mechanics and
things like
you know hawking radiation uh wormholes
and so forth what what is most
fascinating to you about black holes
jessica just on a
personal human to human level what what
fascinates you about these objects
yeah i think it is the mystery it's not
knowing what happens inside them and
knowing you'll never know but somehow
still trying to figure out
this puzzle right
and i i don't know if it'll be
astronomy and astrophysics that helps
answer those questions i i think it's
going to take everyone to try and figure
out what's happening in the inside of a
black hole
yeah i really love this uh you know from
the universe's perspective trying to
understand fundamental physics this this
place where we it really is a deep
mystery and these things are more exotic
than anything we can ever hope to make
on earth
uh you mentioned black holes and and
dark matter and bioreuben observatory
and stuff like that
people often think that the black hole
the milky way is somehow responsible for
dark matter or the behavior of our
galactic orbit which is not but
um uh we i have a video about that uh
somewhere else in the channel
about uh maybe it was on the event
horizon and sagi star detection but um
but i guess one question i have is if
you
you know how many of these things would
you be finding if they could seriously
contribute to the dark matter gap you
know between baryonic and non-baryonic
dark matter how many would you i mean
would you just be overloaded with these
and couldn't even get hubble time
because it's like looking you know
staring directly at the sun or something
yeah so it's a it's a great question so
is dark matter just made up 100 of
primordial black holes and so you were
mentioning the macho project earlier
said no that can't be the case but that
was for a very specific if all
primordial black holes are a specific
mass right let's say the universe
conspires and that dark matter is all
primordial black holes but they run a
huge range of masses stars don't all
have one mass so why should primordial
black holes have all one mass yeah so
maybe they run from moon masses up to
100 solar masses
so if that were the case i i don't think
we yet have the observations to totally
rule out that scenario
so that's something where i think people
are still actively working on is do
primordial black holes exist do they
make up all or some of dark matter and
what is their mass range right
so yeah so i think that's a really super
exciting question could dark matter just
be these these primordial black holes
now even if it is they're still pretty
exotic these are not black holes born
from dying stars they're black holes
that were born at the beginning of the
universe during the big bang and how
does that happen who knows right so i
think there's still a lot of exciting
things to do with primordial black holes
and and still a lot of exciting
experiments to conduct to prove that
they exist or not
excellent
uh next question comes from erin lampa
she says other than being really
interesting and cool what's the main
goal of studying black holes what kind
of science or technology could this
eventually lead to i'll let you answer
that
yeah so in terms of science
understanding the universe you know i
want to know when our star dies what's
going to happen well we think it's going
to turn into a white dwarf but a lot of
our neighbor stars are way bigger than
the sun they're 10 times as massive
what's going to happen when they die are
they going to supernova
and will that impact us or are they just
going to direct collapse into a black
hole are they going to turn into a
neutron star you know we don't know this
is what we're trying to answer so that's
a fun a fun one we're trying to
understand
and then if we want to understand the
whole history of the universe how our
galaxy came to be these stellar mass
black holes play a role they provide a
lot of feedback that when they are
accreting in their early young days they
can have jets and all you know influence
their surroundings out to huge distances
they can heat up the whole galaxy
lots of lots of fun astrophysical
questions
in terms of sort of fundamental physics
i think it'll be a combination of
gravitational waves event horizon
telescope that are where they're probing
this interface between gravity and
quantum mechanics and then a lot of
theoretical work and experimental work
in the labs
so i would say these stellar mass
buckles are more about the astrophysics
we want to learn about the understanding
what the universe is doing around us
interesting
great yes i often say you know the
problem with basic science research like
you and i do is that sometimes it does
produce technology
and then everybody expects it to keep
making you know a faster
internet speed or something like that um
so uh last couple questions before we
wrap up you and i both have telecons we
spend more time on telecons and
telescopes i at least i do um i wish i
could spend more time on telescopes
george anderson's asking what kinds of
things we'll be able to learn once we
have data on thousands of such black
holes or you know some large number when
can we start you know go from n equals 1
to n equals you know 10 to the 10 to the
third or something
yep i want to know how many black holes
are in our galaxy is it 100 million is
it 10 million is it a billion
that's the level of uncertainty we have
we don't know and that tells me how
close is the nearest black hole you know
how how big of a spaceship do i have to
build if i really wanted to go probe an
event horizon for instance
if you want to be uh matthew mcconaughey
in real life yeah right
exactly yeah what's the biggest black
hole what's the smallest black hole
what's the difference between a black
hole and a neutron star do they overlap
in mass space or not yeah so those are
some of the fun questions i hope we can
answer in the not too distant future
amazing uh and let's see the last
question i think we have time for today
we'll have to get you back on
um
uh on the show comes from again ernesto
he gets most uh frequently asked
question of the day uh so he's asking is
it possible that relativistic particles
coming from black holes fall into
gravitation are
interact with gravitational waves and
you could get some kind of amplification
perhaps or compression
from the uh from the uh from somehow
gravitational waves interacting or the
particles interacting with gravitational
waves produced by black holes this is an
isolated one right so this one has no
gravitational radiation jessica am i
wrong that's right this one is
completely dark black hole or neutron
star it has no electromagnetic radiation
that we know of at the moment it might
it's probably a small amount if it's a
neutron star but yeah these are these
are dark enough that we don't see any
big em signals right okay
um
abbas safari suffer i think i asked
would you please answer my important
question
would you not first know what a black
hole is how is it created or how it
looks like before you look at it so i
think this person's asking you know
how can you really tell it's a black
hole and i think well what jessica said
if i don't misinterpret you is that you
as a scientist you want to be cautious
you want to say here are different
possibilities she's not saying it's 100
guaranteed to be a black hole or your
money back uh which is nothing
but uh well actually these people many
of them pay our tax our salary in the
state of california so we can't be too
cavalier about it so i think
if i'm not mistaken jessica that's
that's the answer you you say what the
likely you know possibilities are and
then nature will tell us the right
answer once we have enough data
yep and i think at the center of the
galaxy the milky way the supermassive
black hole that's where we've got the
best results there's we've looked we
have such good data that there's nothing
left people have tried to at least that
we know people have tried to invent
exotic cork stars and all kinds of fun
things that could reside and instead not
be a black hole and all of them have
been disproven by our ability to smash
so much matter into such a tiny tiny
little volume the only thing we know
right now that fits that picture is a
black hole as a black hole well uh
jessica it's been a delight i know my
audience just keeps growing and growing
over a couple hundred people watching us
right now chat about
rogue black holes on the rampage thanks
to the discovery of you and your massive
amazing team at uc berkeley any uh
exciting other op things that you're
interested in uh sharing with the
audience before we break for the next
telecom
sure i think there's lots more black
holes to come and i think there was a
question about the technology i'm really
excited to also help work on the
technology that will make this possible
to measure you know not just one every
once in a while but to grow this into a
tens or hundreds of black holes uh that
we know about in our own milky way would
that be a new telescope or like a
dedicated survey like zwiki or something
so it's a all of the above so reuben and
roman are telescopes that are that are
being built now and will be launched and
available soon and then we're upgrading
the keck adaptive optics systems uh to
make our biggest telescopes capable of
taking the sharpest images and
you know jwst so yeah i think this will
all be with things we're working on
actively today uh so it won't be too
long in our lifetimes for sure and
hopefully in my next round of graduate
students
in the next ten day two decades uh
jessica if you guys like these kinds of
episodes let me know leave a comment uh
if you want to see more office hours
with my brilliant colleagues and friends
from around the world of astrophysics
we've got some exciting episodes coming
up bill phillips who won the nobel prize
in 1997 recorded an episode with him
uh recently about a technology that's
been used to standardize our measurement
of time and space over the millennia so
that's an exciting episode i have
governed shilling who wrote a new book
about uh dark matter that's a coming out
called the elephant in the universe i'm
interviewing him a man by the name of
bernardo castroop is coming on the show
the podcast this summer so let me know
do you want to see more episodes like
this uh with with uh my brilliant
luminous colleagues like jessica uh or
more solo deep dives how would you like
to see the direction of the into the
impossible podcast going in the future
but for now i want to thank jessica so
much i love your work you have an
awesome as i said you have this killer
brand uh it's like louis vuitton of of
astronomy it's been such a delight
talking to you i uh really appreciate it
jessica thank you so much and thank you
everybody for tuning in and we'll tune
in next time for the into the impossible
podcast
thanks so much brian talk to you later
take care bye guys